[Music]
human beings have one foot in the
familiar and one foot in the novel and
we're actually biologically built to be
that way we don't want to run on
autopilot we don't want to live
Groundhog Day doing the same thing
saying the same thing to the same people
all the time on the other hand we don't
want doors to have new types of ways you
unlock them and gravity is flipping
upside down in the English language all
the letters are scrambled every time you
open the newspaper we need some mixture
of the two some sweet spot between
novelty and familiarity and the search
for that sweet sweet spot is not
something with a formula it's a constant
experiment and so in our own lives we're
constantly navigating between the things
that are the touchstones for us where we
feel solidly grounded and the places
where we're flying free and there is an
annette under us we often think that the
most creative people are the ones who
leap straight to the right answers and
inspiration right from the get-go but
actually when you look closely at it
inspiration is usually in the
proliferation of a diversity of options
and what Picasso is - art Beethoven is -
composing in that behind his works lie
an enormous of reservoir of sketches
that Beethoven left and what you see
when you look at those sketches is in
trying out idea after idea after idea
working the material never erasing
anything constantly figuring out all
sorts of options and then picking his
favorite out of those and so one thing
that I'll tell my composition students
is banish the eraser and have lots of
paper never make it that you are
treading over like treating your other
ideas like sandcastles that get washed
away by the sea but rather preserve
everything so you have the maximum array
of choices from which to pull your
ultimate decisions you try to come up as
with as many possible solutions as you
possibly can and you constantly
challenge yourself it's not good enough
to have one answer it's not good enough
to have three answers let me come up
with seven possible answers to this the
physicist Richard Feynman said that his
whole success is a Nobel prize-winning
physicist was that he trained himself
constantly to come up with different
ways of arriving at the right answer so
if he ever hit a roadblock he knew he
could just jump to another way of
approaching the problem and that's just
a wonderful attitude to have with
whatever one is trying to wrestle with
creatively and the second is this
concept of scouting two different
distances so you don't want to just stay
iterating oh I will do a read building
and then we'll do the same building
green and then we'll do a blue that's
not really pushing the envelope very
much but can you do stuff that is fairly
close to the familiar and broaden it all
out into the completely wacky and
everything in between and if you set
that as a creative challenge let me come
up with as many solutions as possible
let me fill this whole spectrum from the
familiar to the wacky then you end up
with a very healthy creative attitude
and you tend to be very stimulated with
ideas and constantly coming up with new
things
you